はい 今まで説明したのは
仏道に入った人がもう何のことなく割り合わせというか
最小限に生活して すぐたちまち心の安らぎと怠けもなくなって
それからすごい明るくなって
すごく気楽に生活する
もう頭怠けてはいけません
ものすごく頭回転しているんです
だけど妄想することもないんです
妄想するのが怠けなんです
だからもう普通の世界では信じられない
もう想像もできない安らぎを感じるんです
それからもっと上の方
悟りの挑戦 だから悟りに挑戦するために
これがないとできないんですよ
だから物にあの姿が決まってると思っちゃうと邪見でしょうに
だから人間で 生命であろうが物であろうが
いつでも多面性を持っていて
もうわからない 決まったものは何もないんだという
すごいこのオープンで置いておかないと
それが邪見を破ることですね
基本的に知識的に邪見を破ること
知識的に破ってもダメなんです
これは実験して発表 なんて言いますか
証明しないと自分で それが悟りの挑戦なんです
で 心の自由っていうのは悟りの挑戦ですね
体も物に依存する 心は感情
妄想 思考 概念 信仰の刺激に依存している
体は物に依存していますよ
だからまあ そんなもので食べなくちゃいけないし
空気を吸わなくちゃいけないし
そんなものを切っちゃうと体が壊れて死んでしまいます
じゃあ心はどうでしょうかと
心も思考 妄想 信仰 あれこれやと依存して回転されているんです
これは心の汚れ 煩悩というんです
で 仏教は体も依存させないでくださいと言わないんです
ご飯食べなさいと言うんです
あのプラナヤーマという瞑想は教えません
仏教は あのプラナヤーマっていうのは
もうできるだけゆっくり
あのヒンドゥー教の瞑想一つなんですね
まあ呼吸することなんです
鼻一つこうやって閉めて
あの日本の人がインドに指導して
まあ女性があの偉そうにね
まあそうやって 穴が 2つあるんだから 2
つでやればいいだけですけどね
それでどれぐらい長く吸えるか
どれぐらい時間かけてゆっくり吐けるかとかね
それからどれぐらい空気を止めているかとかね
もう勝手にやればいいんだから
まあ私はあまり知りませんだけど
それはプラナヤーマという瞑想で
本格的にやる場合は 空気を吸って体が倒れるところまで吐かないでいるんです
汗がタラタラ出て もう体が震え出したりして
できれば意識がなくなるところまでやった方が正しいんです
今はみんなインチキグルたちだから
そこまでやらないんです
それから吐くんです 吐いて止めるんです
止めてる時でも体が倒れるまで止めておくんです
それは本当のプラナ プラナヤーマなんです
で まああのまあ科学的な事実もありますよ
この脳っていうのは 死にかけるとものすごく怯えて活発になるんです
あの火事の馬鹿力という言葉ありますね
それは生命の場合は あの死を経験させちゃうと
この馬鹿力が出るんです
だから まあそれで気分が良くなったとか
病気治ったとかね まあ嘘じゃない
治ったならばね だってもう死に追い込まれると自然に脳が動くんです
生き続けたいんだから
だからヨーガが成功するためにすっごい執着ないとうまくいかないんです
生きていきたいっていう衝動が裏でしっかりあって
だからそれはあの魂が永遠なりとかね
すべてブラフマと個が同じものやとかね
そういう徹底したこの邪見に根付いてやってますから
まあいろいろ結果はありますよ
悟りには達しませんし
智慧は現れません そういうそういう経験があったとしても
すごい馬鹿なんです もう話あんまり知識的な会話できない
だからそれは置いておいて
あの 例えばまあすべて無常は今死んだってもどうったことはないんだと
今死んだって別にどうったことない
そういう人はプラナヤーマやらないし
いや 例えば空気を止めていると
まあまあ冗談でやろうと思って
空気を止めてなんで白石やるんで
そのまま死んだってもいいんじゃないかということになるんだから
その結果が出ないんです
あ 死ぬのは怖い なんとか
これならないんです あ
死ぬか それで終わっちゃいますからね
だから仏教ではそんなことやらなく
初めからの元気なんです
最小限に挑戦する時点でものすごく生き生きしています
とにかく体依存することについてやりすぎ
喋りすぎですけど お釈迦様は体にものを依存することはやめろとかね
あんまり言ってないんで
これは理性の人が言うことじゃないんですよ
ご飯食うなかれとかね
呼吸するなかれとかね
小便出すなかれとか 何やこれと
それは意味がないんですよ
服を着るなかれとかね
裸でいなさいよとかね
あるいは体は裸で体中泥を塗って灰をね
塗って もうガンジー川でも太陽に当たって瞑想しなさいとか
それはないんです で しかし
心の依存にはまあ厳しいんです
肉体はどうしても壊れるんだから
まあ放っておけばいいんです
病気があったっても まあいいんじゃないんでしょうかと
健康だったらまあそれでいいんじゃないんですかねとかね
どちらでもいいんじゃないかということで
どうせ体が老いて壊れて死ぬし
それに引っかかったらもう大損なんですね
だから心の依存をなくして自由になるんですね
心がものに 概念に 感情に依存していますね
だからそれが煩悩というんですね
心の自分を発展しないで
ものに依存して生き続けたいんです
だから車に依存すると体力がつかないでしょうに
車で行くぞと歩きませんよと言ったら
体は弱いまんまで いえ
歩きましょうと言ったら
その人は精神的にも肉体的にも強くなる
心の場合も同じなんです
心も何かに依存したいので
妄想に激しく依存しているんですよ
だからずっと妄想ばっかりして心はすすくんです
何か考えなきゃ 何か信仰がなければ生きていられないんです
それは心の依存 心が依存するということは
心はずっと弱いまんまなんです
100メートルでも車でしか歩かないんだったら
その人はものすごい弱いまんまで
体はね 成長しない 同じ法則で依存
心が依存すると 心は全く成長しないんですね
未熟なままでおくんです
で 勝利を目指す人は この依存から心を解放しなくてならないんです
だからものに依存迷われる
心がものに依存しないようにする
修行に対する では この修行に必需品は何なのかと
この場合も仏教はあり合わせでと言っても良いのですが
実はそれさえもいらないんです
心の自由を目指すためには
あり合わせもいりません
必需品は何もないんです
最小解脱に達するための最小限の必需品が
それでも考えておきましょう
というより 絶対必要なものは一応あるんです
悟りに達するために絶対必要なものは一応あります
何ですかね これを具体的に考えてみます
煩悩 煩悩が現れるシステム
目がある 見えるもの 対象
色ですね ある 情報が触れることによって眼識が生まれる
この感覚に対して良い悪いなどを判断する
そこで欲 怒りなどが生まれる
目に絶えず流れる情報によって心が汚れていくんです
目がありますね 見えるものがありますね
触れちゃうと見えるんですね
それから良いか悪いか
いろいろ判断するんですよ
心が汚れるんです では
目にものを触れることは絶えず起きているでしょ
ずっと ということは ずっと心が汚れているんです
眼識とそれに関連して
起こる そのその他の色に対して
心が汚れない方法を見つけなくてはならないんです
だから 目を目を見えないようにするんじゃなくて
目にものを触れてずっと見えてますけど
なんか汚れない方法はないのかと
見ても汚れない方法はないのかを探さなくちゃいけないんです
耳がある 音がある 両方が触れることによって
耳識が生まれる この感覚に対して良い悪いなどを判断する
そこで欲 怒りなどが生まれる
耳に絶えず流れる情報によって心が汚れていくのです
耳識とそれに関連して起こるその他の色に対して
心が汚れない方法を見つけなくてはならないんですね
前のスライドと同じ文章なんです
わざと全く同じくしたんです
それで鼻と香り 舌と味
体と触れるものの間でも同じようなプロセスが起こるんです
ということは どこからでも我々の心が汚れるんです
また 意と情報との概念ですなどの間でも同じプロセスが起き
汚れた思考が回転するんです
起きていると耳鼻から心汚れるだけじゃなく
じゃあ寝ていたらどうでしょうか
とすると 心自分で勝手に夢見たりとか
それでも汚れるんです
認識が汚れてしまう勘見つけて解除するのは修行なんです
目が悪いわけじゃないし
見えるものが悪いわけじゃないんです
触れたことも悪いわけじゃないんです
そこで良い良い悪いと判断して汚れるところ
どこでこの問題が起こるのか
その場所 局部を見つからなくちゃいけないんです
見えたら煩悩が起こるというと救いがなくなる
あ 見える見える 見えたら心が汚れますからと
当たり決まってるんだと言っちゃうと救いようがないんですよ
音を聞いたら心汚れますよと
だったらもうそう勘違いして
大乗仏教ではね 人を悟れませんよとも言ってますからね
あんまりにもバカバカらしい
お釈迦様の教典でそんなのはもういい加減にしてくださいと言ってますからね
眼識に関連して認識が起こる時
何か間違いが生じるんですよ
ただ 目目にものを触れて認識が生まれるでしょう
眼識が それから認識が生まれるんですね
そこで何か間違いが起こるんです
それはデータを瞬間単位で認識しないで
大量のデータをまとめてひと塊にして認識するからです
あまりにも我々は鈍くて見えただけで見ないんです
たくさんデータが触れるまでバカみたいくいて
あ 見えたと言うんです
瞬間が見えてるつもりでしょ
そうじゃないんです あの日本の庭園ではなんか竹なんかあるでしょ
水がちょこちょこと落ち入って
それからポトンとそれが落ちて音を立てるなんか器具がありますね
だからあの竹がもう上がっていて
水がちょっと入っても落ちま落ちません
もうちょっと入っても落ちません
もうちょっと適量に水の量が入ったら
竹がポーンと落ちてきれいな音を出してまた上がるんですね
そこはみんな喜んでいるんですね
なんて美しいですかと
日本人の考え方と それ見てみると
私にそんなくだらんことじゃなくて
この煩悩ある人の認識過程はそんなもんであると
水一滴一滴は認識しない
竹の穴なんて吸うって言うんですか？開いてるね
え？いや あの開いてる場所を何て言いますか
え？節 だから竹の節の中で
ある程度の水で ある量の水がたまらないと
だからそれはどれぐらい量かというと
この竹の重さなんですね
つなげてる重さ じゃあそれは無明にしてください
無知にしてください だから無知が強ければ強い
いわゆる竹の後ろの方が重ければ重いほど
節の中に大量の水が入らなくちゃあかんでしょ
もし竹の後ろの方がすっごく軽い空気のような軽いんだったら
水一滴でもトンと落ちるんです
だから私に見えるのはそういう世界なんです
皆様に何が見えるかわかりませんだけど
そこが問題なんです データがある大量で入って塊にならないと
見えた 聞こえたということにしないんです
データをひと固まりにすることは不可能です
本当はそれ非科学的で成り立たないんです
ひと固まりにすることはできないんです
それが間違いということなんですね
データは瞬間瞬間現れて消える波です
見えると言ったっても
瞬間瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 波ですよ
一つのデータが消えてから次のデータが入るんです
目にも耳にも 一つのデータが入って
それ消える 次のデータ入って消える
次のデータが入って消えるという流れなんです
ですから ひと塊だと思っても
そちらに実在する塊はありません
もう消えているんです
今あると認識するのは過去の今ないデータなんです
だから壁見えた あ 見えない
壁見てるんです だから禅問答でありますよ
あんたにあの こうやってフラフラしてる旗見えますか？と弟子に聞くんですよ
弟子ははい 見えますよと
お前の心が揺れてるんだよと
禅師が返事するんです
旗がゆらゆらしてるんじゃないんだよと
お前の心が揺れているんだ
それは正しいんです 言っていることが
旗が風に触れて揺れるように見えたならば
それはそれじゃなくて
過去を終わった出来事を見ているんです
ということは心が揺らいでいるということなんです
だからそれで何のことなく
弟子が全然悟りに達してないんだと
で 禅師に怒られます お前ダメやと
だから弟子もどうすればいいんですかね
見えないと言ったっても怒られるし
見えると言ったっても怒られるし
旗が揺らいでいると言ったっても怒られるし
揺らぎないと言ったって
お前は何を言うのかと言うし
だからやっぱり悟ってないと答えられないということなんです
で 定者の発見  ６つの感覚器官も ６つの対象も春滅して流れるものであり
無常であり 実体塊ではないと発見するんですよ
これをだから今私は見えると言っても
これは終わったことを見えると言ってるんだよと
目にはデータが瞬間瞬間しか入りませんよと
入って消えちゃいますよと
あのだから竹の例えで考えればいいんですよ
しかし その場合は 竹には一応実際水が溜まってるんだからね
我々は心もそうだと思ってますけど
そうでないんです 心の場合は
心の竹には水一滴入ったら
それは漏れて出ていく
次の水一滴入ったら漏れて出ていく
それである程度で出てたら見えたというようなことなんです
だから 存在しないものを我々は認識しているんです
このシステムを発見するんですよ
瞑想で欲や怒りなどの煩悩がないものに
存在しないものに 幻想に
捏造したものに対して生まれるものだと発見するんです
今 私は怒っているんですけど
あれは実際もしないことに怒っているんだと
いわゆるウサギの角に対して怒っているんだよと
存在もしないんだから
あまりにもバカバカらしいでしょうに
だからそのそのからくりを発見しなくちゃいけないんですね
幻覚が起こるからくりを発見すると同時に
心は煩悩から解放される
自由になる 悟りに出す
悟りの心理学的な説明はそんなもんです
６つの感覚器官が だから瞑想する人にはどうしても欠かせない必需品は ６つの感覚器官ですよ
それないんだからね 誰も悟ってないでしょうね
やっぱり備わってないんだから
６もいりませんよ 一つの感覚器官に集中して
幻覚を引き起こすからくりを発見すれば十分です
６つもいりません 修行する誰でも一つに集中して
そこでからくりを発見するんです
生命には人間にはその ６の感覚器官も
備わってます 生命といえば ６
もない生命もいますよ
目がない生命もいるし
耳がない生命もいるんだけど
人間だったら 6つもあるんですね
全部もう完備なんですよ
最低胃の感覚もなければ生命ではありません
物体です ものです だからどんな生命にも
アメーバにしたっても胃はあるんです
目はないんです アメーバには耳もないんです
味もない 舌もないんです
しかし 胃だけあるんです
これ アメーバにもある能力ですよ
大変ひどい目に遭ってますのは
妄想ばっかりしたりして
だから生命には 6つもない生命もいますけど
生命といったら胃ぐらいはあります
悟りに達するために必要なものは
感覚のある体ですね 肉体
眼耳鼻と意識ですね そんなもん全部書いてないんですけどね
あんまり舌は瞑想には使わないんです
鼻もあまり使ってはいけないとは思ってますけど
実際修行する場合はね
人間というのはそれが備わっているシステムなので
人間ならそれだけで悟りに達するために必需品が備わっているんです
人間といったら眼耳鼻舌身意あるでしょうに
だから悟るために必要なものは全部完備です
要するにあり合わせもいらないということです
あり合わせっていうのは
ちょっと必要なものを余計に取るってことでしょ
悟りの場合はそれもいらないんです
生きる時は必要ですけど
しかし 鋭い集中力と精進がいるが
それは必要です それは修行により現れるから問題はないんです
私に鋭い集中力ないんだぞとかね
精進もない 修行してみればそれ生まれてきますから
全然問題にならないんです
ということは 悟れないという文句は全く言えない状態なんです
だからこのお釈迦様からはそう簡単には逃げられません
自分が恥かけるようにできているんです
悟るために必要なのは目耳鼻身体だけです
しかし 精進たらもう集中力とも必要ですけど
それはないんだ やってみればそれは生まれますよと
誰にもないんだと 初めはそれは
それは修行で生まれるんだからね
だから何も文句言えない世界です
それでちょっとパーリ語を紹介しますけど
ヤッタコアウソ ナジャティナジーヤティナニーヤティ
ナチャワティナウパジャティ
ナハンタンガマニーナ
ローカッサンタンニャーテーヤンディットダッテイヤン
パッテイヤンティワダーナチャハンアウソアッパッローカッサンタン
ドゥッカッサンタキリヤンワダミ
アピチャーハンアウソ
イマスミミンイエ ビャッマッハケーカレーバレー
これは円はいりますね
ササンヒンミサマナケーローローカンチャパンニャペーミローカサマダンチェローカニローダンチェローカニローダガーミンチェパティパダンパティパッダパティパダンティという
これなかなか大変訳できなくできなくなったんです
一応まあちょっと省略して
なんとか訳のようなものは書いてますけど
やったな ジャーヤティ
生まれることはない なジーヤティ
生きることもない なニーヤティ
死ぬこともない なチャワティっていうのはもう消えること
それも死ぬことない ない
なウパパジャティ 再び生まれることもないところがあるんだよと
やって そのところにはなー
ガマネーナ それがローカッサンタン
世界の果てなんです 我々が生きる世界で終わりだと
終わったところで その世界の果てにはガマネーナ
歩いてはいけませんと
歩いてということの肉体的な動きでは無理だということなんです
それはもうはっきりとこの経典で説明してますよ
古い人間だから この高速とか知らない
宇宙が無限にあることも当時は知らなかったんです
でお釈迦様だけ知っていたんです
そこであるローヒタというもうローヒタッサという神がお釈迦様に世間の果てに歩いて行けますか？行けませんよと言うと
まさにその通りですよ
自分が昔々すごい超能力者でいたんだと
ものすごく体が速かったんだと
どれぐらい速かったかというと
この 100人ぐらいの能力ある人間が 4人一つの柱で四方を見て立っていて
いっぺんにこの 100人分の力があるんですよ
それで矢を放つと 私は全部地面に落ちる前に取って元に戻ってくることはできますよと
で これ速さ そこで自分が一つ足を踏むと
西側の海に足一つ入れて
また足を入れる 東側の海がある
だからこれ地球平らと思ったら分かりやすいんですよ
地球平らで周りが海やと
言うと一歩っていうのは地球を乗り越えたことなんです
だから丸いと感じではちょっとイメージが出てこないんです
当時で インドでは地球は平らだと思っていたんです
そこで水平線の向こう側は海があるんだと
東であろうが西であろうが
もう東西南北全部海であると
これ この紙のこの長さっていうのは
東の海から西の海まで一歩の方の長さなんですね
そのぐらい速さで動いて歩いたんだと
宇宙も体も 栄養取ったりする時間だけ休んで
何千万年も歩いたんですけど
途中で死んじゃったんだよと
行けなかったんだと 宇宙の果てに
だから当時のインド人には分からなかったでしょうね
現代の宇宙の考え思考と比較すると当たり前のこと
だからお釈迦様はよく見事に本当のことを言ったんだよと
歩いてはいけませんよと言ったところで
お釈迦様はさらに言うんですよ
やっぱりといっても その宇宙の果てに行けない限りは
すごい境地に達しませんよと
生まれることも生きることも
死ぬことも 菩提を得るも何もない
だからこれ神話的に考えればいいんですよ
あるどこかである町があると
その町に入る人は決して病気にならないんだと
決して年取らないんだと
決して死なないんだと
言っただけで十分訳言っちゃうとみんな行くでしょう
お釈迦様は残念ながらその町には歩いてはいけないんだよ
体動かすことでは 飛んで行ったっても
体動かすことそれができないんだ
ではどうしようかということになるんです
あるんだけど いけないんでしょうと
だからお釈迦様 そのそういうのはすごい文学的でもありながら
すごい哲学なんです しかし
お釈迦様は言うんですよ
ね チャーハンは嘘アッパットアローカッサンタン
その世間の果てに達しないと
ドッカサンタキジャンはだ
苦しみを乗り越え 乗り越えると苦しみの終焉見つかるということはないんだよ
だから世間の世界の果てに行かなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 動いてはいけないんです
アピチャハンアーソー
しかし 君に言いますよと
いますみんにはビャッマだけカレーばれ
このこの両手伸ばしたぐらいの長さのこの体
ビャーマっていうのはこれくらい長さですね
だからだいたい平均的な身長っていうのはこれ伸ばしたぐらいですよ
時々それよりもあるし
それより低い人もいますけど
平均取っちゃうとまあ両手伸ばしたぐらいですよ
ササンにヒンミサマナケ
体に感覚があるんですね
この感覚ある この体の中でローカンチャパンジャペ
これ こちらに宇宙大世界があるんだよと私は設定しますよと
ローカサムデア宇宙の現れもこの中にあるんだよと
ローカニローダ 宇宙の終焉もこちらにあるんだよ
それからローカニローダガミニンチャパティパダ
その方法も この両手伸ばしたらぐらいの長さの体の中にありますよ
どんな？だから動かす必要ないんだよ
この中にすでにあるんだよという経典です
だから意味はあまりあの
これうまくいかないんですか
精霊師の世界の果てに歩いて達することができません
しかし 世界の果てに達しないで苦を乗り越えることもできません
しかし 私は感覚がある
これ読み方わからないんですけど
辞書には  人ですかね  人
人拾い  人拾いの肉体において世界世界の現れること
世界の滅と世界の滅に達する道があると説きます
これ説きますとこうやって訳したんですけど
お釈迦様がもう断定的に結論付けておくんです
だからパンニャーペーネっていうのは事実データを見て結論に達することなんです
世界を知り尽くすということは
世間という言葉ですね
この肉体と感覚の働きを知り尽くすことです
世界を知り尽くすことになるんです
自分の体のことを知り尽くしちゃえば
一切知ったことになるんです
世界とは一切の生命のこととして理解しておきましょう
こちら世界 世界というのは
この物理的な この空間的な世界というよりも
生命のことなんです では
世界を知り尽くるために必需品とは？ただ自分の感覚と肉体だけで十分です
それで知ります ここで一切智者という言葉がありますね
一切とは 眼耳鼻舌身意と色声香味触法と触れることで現れる生まれる眼識などの六識として定義されています
一切はそれだけです 他あるのか
このシステムを知ることは一切を知ることなのです
では 一切智者になるために必要なのは
ただ自分の身体だけ 勝利者になるために
あ これ漢字があべこべですね
数数でしたっけ あの 何て言いますかね
お坊さんたち持っている数珠
おそらく同じ漢字で  それであってます
合ってますか うん お数も聖地巡礼も滝も清らかな環境も
精進料理も有名な道場も
その他その他何も要りませんよ
一切智者になるためには
代表して受難してくれる人も
預言者も救済主も残念なことにいりません
みんな無駄をやっています
自分の体だけあれば 完全たる悟りに達する
苦を乗り越える 一切の勝利者になる
だから いかに人間は無駄なことをやっているのかということなんです
何も要りません ブッダが語る
ヤンビッカーウェーサッチャーラカラニーヤンサーワカーナンヒテーシナアヌカンパケーナアヌカンパンウーパダーヤカタンヴォタンマヤンエーターニビッカーウェー
ルックムーラーニエーターニスンヤーガーラーニジャーヤタビッカーウェーマパマーダッタマパッチャーヴィパッティサーリノーアホアッタアヤンヴォーアンマカンアヌーサーサニ
今日の講演みたいにお釈迦様がすごい明確にすべてシステムを分析してから
最後にこれを教えるんです
ヤンビッカーウェーサッチャーラ
サッチャーラというのは師匠のこと
カラニーヤン 師匠たるものがやるべきこと
サーワカーナンというのは弟子のこと
サーワカーナン ヒテーサン
弟子のことは心配する
弟子の繁栄 成長を期待する
師匠だから アヌカンパケーナ
心配する アヌカンパングーパだから
師匠が弟子のことを心配して
やるべきことはかたんおたんや
もうやりましたよ だから今日の講演でも理解しておけば
それ以上何もないはずなんです
やるべきことはもうやりましたと
師匠の仕事は教えてあげること
だから エーターニビッケルカムラン
いくらでも木の下あるでしょうに
スンヤーガーラーに空き家もあっちこっちあるでしょうに
ジャハエテビッケ修行しなさいよと
マパマーダって怠ること
うろうろしているんじゃないんだよと
マッパッチャヴィパッササーナ
あとで後悔するなよと
だからこの弟子を心配する憐れみ
憐れむ師としてするべきことは行いました
ビクラよ 木の下がある
空き家がある 怠ることなく修行に励みなさい
あと後悔しないようにと
だから何も要りません
どこかで腰を掛けることができれば
どこでもできますからね
悟りに達しますよと で
あっという間に終わりましたね
そういうことで 仏教は
このものの多面性 それは我々の俗世間では大変役に立ちます
人間も多面性を持っていて
決まってないんです 何一つ
それを覚えておけば かなり頭が回転する
明るくなる トラブルが消えちゃう
生活する時も お釈迦様の最小原理ということで生活してみると
すごい安らぎを感じる
それから悟りたければそれも要りません
体さえあれば悟りに達すると
一切一切になるんだよというポイントです
長い時間かかったんですけど
ただそれだけ どうもありがとうございます